hi welcome to microsoft research summit
i'm tahina ramanandro i'm a member of
the rice team researching software
engineering
at microsoft research relevant
and today i'm talking about everparse
which is a framework that we are
developing at microsoft research redmond
at rise
for automatically generating formally
verified secure parsers for cloud
integrity
ever parse is actually a wide
collaboration
between microsoft research
and microsoft project groups as well and
also with external contributors and
former microsoft research interns
everpass is tackling the challenges of
secure parsing
attacker-controlled inputs
can may be incorrectly handled
either if this format the data format is
insecurely designed
or if the parser itself is buggy whether
it is incorrect with respect to the data
format
or whether the parser itself isn't safe
with respect to memory safety or has
performed for ovarians or anything like
that
we want to
get rid of all of those or main or much
sorry
we want to get rid of those incorrect
handling of attacker-controlled inputs
with ever powers
because those passing bugs when they
arise they are catastrophic
attackers may properly craft inform
packet to gain access to critical
systems or to recover sensitive data
and whenever you have such for data
formats
they are very
they are often embedded into each other
and so they incur layered parsers one
parser for each layer of format
and thus with each layer with each
parser comes
more risk of failure
and such passwords are actually
ubiquitous
network communication formats and so on
many such formats are legacy
and even for those formats that are
actually standardized
many parsers that pass them are mostly
legacy parsers that have been around for
dozens of years
which classes of passing buzz do we mean
by passing birth we mean insecure format
design for instance
we want to authenticate a message by
serializing it and hashing it
is it at all possible
sometimes not
if the message can have several binary
representations
then
one can claim that a bitcoin transaction
has happened or not or has not happened
by saying that
you store one version one version of the
byte representation of your transaction
but you hash another one and so you can
claim that your transaction has not
happened or
you can forge a certificate signature
if the format
if the format is not valuable so if the
format is malleable that is
if the validator has several ways of
accepting
a message
even if the format is safe or secure
the personal implementation itself may
be incorrect or unsafe
for instance in windows 10 the bad
neighbor bug
incurs improper handling of informed
icmp v6 router packets
which once an attacker crafted the
e-form packets
in a cleverly cleverly enough
leads to some form of control that is
the attacker gains control of the router
and
the whole
system
and more infamously
heartbleed
is actually a parser bug
it comes from a buffer overrun in a
parser for tls
coming with openssl and
other
tls parsers in the world
where attackers can send informed
packets to exploit this buffer overrun
and by exporting that buffer overrun
they can read sensitive data beyond the
end of the array sensitive data in
memory
so that's what we want to avoid
many such formats are legacy formats
they are designed for compactness for
binary compatibility
with the type represent the data
representation of the types
for a given programming language in such
a way that the data can be mappable in
the sense that serialization is just a
mem copy and parsing is just a
validation
followed by your interpret cast which is
specifically a c language crc plus
percentage feature
that makes parsing and serialization
efficient
without copies
but
prone to
bugs if validation is not done properly
but even if the data formats are
standardized either by rfcs
or by semi-formal notation in the rfcs
or in other notations such as asn 1
then
standardized formats are no guarantee
of secure parts
in itself
the format may very well be not well
designed
for instance they may still incur
several possible
binary presentations for a single
message
and thus
incurring authentication issues
and even if the formats are secure
the parser in the serializer may not be
very well correctly implemented with
respect to
the functional correctness with respect
to the data format
or
with respect to memory safety or other
properties
so
to overcome those problems we at
microsoft research
come up with everparse
a mathematically proven parser generator
with ever parse
we aim at abolishing handwritten
low-level binary format pairs parsers
instead
we let the user specify data formats
using a high level declarative notation
and from this description
the user just presses a button
and never pass automatically generates
performance low level parsing code
and the generated code can integrate
seamlessly with existing code bases
the generated code we enjoy property is
formally proven for non-valuability that
is the uniqueness of a representation so
that
the message can be serialized and hashed
for authentication
the generated code
will be memory safe no buffer variants
the generated code will be
arithmetically safe that is no integer
overflows or anything like that
the generated code will be functionally
correct with respect to the high level
specification of the data format
that is all packets that are informed
with respect to the data format
will be
rejected
we also provide an additional guarantee
of the absence of double fetches in the
sense that the validators produced by
everpass we read data no more than once
thus
there will no there will be no such bugs
as time of check versus time of use that
is the data that is read during
validation will be the same as the data
used while processing the packet
in practice
the user rewrites a format description
using
a high-level data format description
language for ever parse
with that
ever parse
just by pressing a button
will automatically generate code for
formal specification of the data format
and the low-level implementation
of the corresponding validators parser
sensorizer
and with the verified libraries for
combinators then
this verified code
will have a proof
that it is safe that it is correct with
respect to the data format
and this code will be also fast because
from the from the generated code
generated by ever parse
we will generate
safe high performance c code
the code generated by ever parse is
actually written in a language called
f-star
is a primary language and proof
assistant based on type theory that can
prove theorems about programs
in a nutshell
f-star is a programming language and
proof assistant which provide logical
foundations of programs and proofs for a
series of domain-specific languages
on top of a star
we define a very we define low star
which is a domain-specific language for
verifying c programs
they for verifying assembly code
still
for doing
proofs for concurrence and concurrent
systems and distributed systems with
separation logic
and ever parse
we for
we for which we design
a data format language
that is a
domain-specific language on top of
f-star and then from an f-star program
we can automatically generate
code
in various languages that can interface
with existing code
f-star is already used all over the
world by billions of unsuspecting users
either in cloud infrastructure
for automated parsing
of untrusted data for virtualization
network virtualization with microsoft
hyper-v
for blockchain applications
for verified crypto in the linux kernel
for protocols for secure communications
quick
tls signal wireguard and so on
but even for fintech
where
where people want correctness of
verifiable computations
or co-trading specifications and
algorithms
or even core crypto in election guard by
microsoft
so an f-star program is actually
a functional program which is a
functional implementation of of some
algorithm
this implementation
comes with
a specification that is the property
that we want for the return value
under the hypotheses
on the input arguments
and then the correctness of the program
with respect to the specification
is checked by f star sending
a verification condition to
an smt an smt prover
developed at microsoft research
and then
once the program is verified f-star can
generate efficient c code for this
implementation
verification of such code will actually
impose no runtime performance overhead
because all verification is done
statically before
generating the c code
in practice
we use f-star
on more complex codes such as
cryptographic algorithms where we
specify cryptographic algorithms
mathematically and we can write
the next implementation for such a
cryptographic algorithm and then we
automatically
generate an efficient c implementation
for that algorithm
but with everparse
everything like that is done
automatically that is the user does not
need to write f star code
they only need to write a format
description and ever parse will as a
push button application
ever parse will generate
the ftr code corresponding to the formal
specification and the implementation of
the validators at the same time
and thus
both the code and the proof are
generated automatically by overpowers
we use everparse
with verified f-star applications for
network protocols such as tls
for verified tls secure channel with the
formal security model
ever parse
with evopar so we produce handshake
message formats
we parse and serialize them
for quick
we write a verified quick record layer
with enough star
with a formal security model
for quick
we use ever parse to do parsing
initialization of quick record layer
messages
with additional proof
that the validators are proven constant
time
in such a way that if even if a packet
is informed
validation itself will not reveal
sensitive data
by uh
check by deciding whether the packet is
informed or not
we also use ever parse
for verified f-star applications such as
dice riot
which is a verified measure measured
boot for embedded devices in in the
internet of things iot
for which with ever parse
we produce sn1 x509 certificates
which we serialize from right to left
for length prefix data
but with everparse we can also go beyond
just verified applications
everpass allows us to produce a verified
secure parsers for windows and asia
in the context of the microsoft hyper-v
network virtualization components
our goal is to protect hosts and guests
from attacks based on malformed packets
so we generate everparse validators for
network packets that come to the host
or to the guests through the network
and we integrate such everpass generated
parsers into the existing c and c plus
plus code base for microsoft hyper-v
thus
every network packet
that passes through ever hyper-v
in windows or azure is validated by ever
parse
to harden such critical applications
written in cnc plus plus
we need to tackle a diversity of
existing wire formats which are designed
for efficiency compactness and api
compatibility
for those formats parsing and
serialization are done by mem copy and
re-interpret casts
instead of writing such parser sentences
by hand
we designed a new specification language
to capture a wide variety of these
formats
with ever parse we produce functionally
correct and memory safe
validators of these formats
and those validators are also proven
double fetch free
and then we interpose such validators at
the attack surface
to ensure that informed data will not
reach the rest of the system
the everpass language for data format
descriptions we call it 3d for
dependent data descriptions
it's a source language of message
formats
basically
for those data formats that we are
tackling in microsoft hyper-v
those are basically c data types
that we just need to augment with
constraints on values
variable length data structures
and actions
for instance here in this example
we have a system
with simple fields
that we just augment with constraints on
their values those constraints can be
just on the values of each field
but they can also incur values of the
previous fields for instance the max
field here depends on the value of both
max and min fields
we can also do tagged unions
usually such tag unions are described in
c as untagged unions and the
relationship between the tag
and the case of the union
is implicit
in ever parse
we make it explicit by saying that a
union is parameterized with the value of
the tag that we choose the case of that
union
and then
a message that is attacked union will be
a struct with a tag
in the case of the union depending on
the value of that tag
the same goes for variable length data
structures
in c
the variable length array is the last
field of a struct whose length is
unspecified
that is the relationship between the
byte length field and the size of the
samples array here
is implicit
in ever parse
we make it explicit by saying that
the size of the samples array will be
equal to this to the value of the byte
length field
we can even have the combination of the
two constraints and variable link
structure data structures
and the values and constraint
can be arbitrary expressions
and once we have validated our packet
we can extract such information
from the packets
for
the application to process
the application we then produ actually
provide
an outparameter to the validator
to which the action in red here
will store the value red during
parsing and thus
we guarantee that the out parameters
will be
provided type save values with respect
to the data format
so
with ever
we managed to model
tcp
as
a data format that
we that we described using the ever
parse
the data format language 3d
with constraints
and variable length structures
from
and for
for a tcp message
we have a tag union
for options of a tcp message that we
take
through an explicit case type for tag
unions in never parse
my colleague asim rastogy
will perform a demo of ever parse to
describe in more detail the tcp example
and other examples
so i invited i invite you to watch
the demo that asim will perform
or never parse
the generated c code generated by ever
parse after verification
has to be human readable so we make it
so
that it can be human readable for
auditing purposes
and it can be human patchable for
emergency purposes
thus we provide a way to propagate
commands from the source data from a
specification
to the c code
and we generate predictable descriptive
names in the c code
the guarantees that we provide on the c
code
are that
the function will return true if and
only if
the bytes in the base buffer provided to
the function
contains a valid byte representation of
the form specification for a packet
we also provide the guarantee that the
function will not read
bytes of the base by of the base array
more than once
and that the function will not mutate
the input but will mutate only
at most to the out parameters provided
by the users
for actions
the performance of the generated c code
generated by other parse
is fast in the sense that
we were given the target of no less than
sorry of less than two percent speed
overhead we actually managed to have no
measurable overhead for validators for
hyper-v
in some cases our code is even more
efficient
by virtue of eliminating your needed
copies from the client code hyper-v in
the sense that
validators operate in place
they don't perform unnecessary copies
and since validators only read data at
most ones
client code no longer needs to copy the
data before passing it to the validator
and that's where we can gain in
performance
even if our specifications are layered
we manage it so that we perform one
single
single validation pass
and so we we can fail early that is if
a failure for a lower layer
occurs
then we don't need
to
complete the validation for the higher
layer because we know that the packet
will fail validation and so we can fail
early and so we can have more efficient
code even in case of failure
for other applications such as bitcoin
the generated code generated by ever
parse
can be even faster
such as more than 12 times faster
than baseline code that actually
parses bitcoin
blockchain transactions by making copies
that we can avoid with everpass
validators
in practice
our scenarios that we carefully chose
forever parts are actually ultra high
value
because the back scenarios for
our hyper-v
applications
are actually catastrophic for the entire
cloud
if
an attacker can send an informed packet
to gain control
of the system
with layered protocols within
incremental parsing
we can do early failure
when a lower layer fails
even if the higher layer has not
completed validation yet
with hyper-v
we had ever passed to generate four
critical message format validators
and many more to come
with ever parse
we managed to replace large code with
the manageable specification in the
sense that we know we now just need to
write
smaller data format specifications
in the thousands of lines
to replace validators which can do
tens of thousands of lines so we already
we gain at least one order of magnitude
for code size
the main challenge then remaining
is how to discover a specification
because even though the specification
of the data format may come from an
official standard
the implementation that we are
interested in is actually implementing a
validator for proprietary specification
that is intentionally different for
background compatibility purposes
or other purposes
and this incurs complex testing matrices
to check that we are not rejecting too
many packets
with respect to what we should
in the sense that the data format that
we specify
may be too strict with respect to some
scenarios that we still want
to allow
everpass is still an ongoing project
even though we have already had success
with hyper-v
we want to go beyond
we want to be able to validate instead
of validating from a fixed
byte buffer we want to validate from the
data stream
so that
we can we can perform validation for
streaming
and streaming uh
communication protocols
we also want to generate parse trees for
more structured packet processing than
just
individual
out parameters provided by
the application we want to generate
parse trees and we want to prove their
correctness with respect to the data
format specification
we want to
perform better error handling
to diagnose when a packet is to be
rejected
and we want to go beyond just validation
and parsing
we want to leverage also f-star to
verify state machines and protocols
with separation logic
and we also want
to make data format specification
discovery easier
with some form and some amount of ai
with that
we will be able to tackle more
applications with other parts
such as asn 1 for x509 certificates
which will currently cover
a small subset for their riot
we want to cover much more of it
for x509
we are currently working on tcp and udp
and other network communication
protocols
and we are also
aiming to
apply other parts for other formats such
as documents
disk storage
or even streaming
communication media
ever parse finds its place among other
hardening and verification frameworks
usually
general purpose for programming
methods
are actually
providing
better guarantees such as functional
correctness and securities
but with the high cost
for the user in terms of proof
proof contents and so on
but with other parse
when we focus
on data formats
we can eliminate the need for users to
provide proofs
they can just generate
validators and their proofs
just by pressing a button
and that makes ever parse the swiss spot
for formal verification
we gain a strong mathematical guarantees
of safety and correctness
the validators produced are probably
correct by constructor construction with
zero proof effort for the user
the code generated is high performance
and thus passers written by hand
are a thing of the past
ever parse
now allows to have a high return on
investment with respect to the attack
surface for parsers which are
ubiquitous everpass is open source you
can find it on github
and for more information you can contact
us by email
thank you for your attention
and enjoy
microsoft research summit 2021